foreign
things first of all
Colombia had serious covid mandates and
travel restrictions which it has
recently lifted I was which was why we
weren't going to go originally yep I was
required to have a negative covid test
within I think 24 hours of travel to get
into the country and they did ask me for
it so that is still there but there was
no other restriction but I noticed the
following interesting pattern
I saw
far more people wearing masks than I
would say is true anywhere in the United
States that I've been really in the last
six months
um which if you were to compare between
American states I would say that masks
were a really good proxy for how crazy
people were over covet narrative right
at this point yeah this was absolutely
not the case in Colombia in fact the
pattern was
random as far as I could tell you would
frequently see people
walking down the street
talking enjoying life and one was
wearing a mask and the other wasn't
wearing a mask they're outdoors and I I
began to puzzle over this because you
know it's such a you know a flash point
in our culture you know whether you are
or aren't on board with whatever the
narrative is that you know it's really
it's it's Wrecking relationships and
there was no sign of that here so the
question is really why if there's no
sign of that if people don't you know if
one person who believes in The Mask
isn't feeling the need to implore their
friend oh you should wear it too because
you might get coveted and it'll be this
that and the other what is going on was
it always so I mean I have I have seen
pairs of people walking down the street
in you know west west of the mountains
on the west coast uh in which one is
masked and one is not uh I think every
time the woman is masked and the man is
not when when it is a couple like that
is that a pattern that you noticed uh I
would say it was more women than men but
it was there was really very little
signal that I could find maybe there was
signal and I just didn't figure it out
but anyway I also know some other things
um that I think are connected and I'll
tell you what I put together which I did
run by
um my host and he he I think thought it
was credible but the doctor who put
together the conference who I don't I
don't know if we asked him if we could
mention yeah I feel confident we can at
least just say uh Dr Ben
um so what the other thing I noticed was
that
Colombians
were very much going on about their
lives there was much less of a sense of
coveted trauma having Disturbed normal
patterns this looked like Latin
Americans doing what Latin Americans do
right I was there over a weekend in
Bogota people were
dancing not only were they dancing in
places where dancing was the thing but
you know couples would get up and they
were dancing in a cafe because the song
that was playing delighted them or
whatever so people were falling in love
they were holding hands they were
dancing they were singing they were
there was a great uh I I had to work a
little bit to find an authentic food
place and I was uh getting dinner there
in the place because you were staying in
like conference land yeah unfortunately
I was in conference land yeah so it was
a long walk to anywhere but
um but
there was a great really good band
playing a lot of this is at the
Colombian Steakhouse that you found yeah
they were they were next door and they
were playing lots of uh
Latin rock songs that I didn't recognize
but that were compelling and then
occasional covers of songs that I you
know both know and like I can't name off
the top of my head what the Colombian
music oh we got a cat with something in
his mouth here if uh if that is worth
dealing with it
um we're doing a little predation
interlude here
yeah uh so you know I'm just thinking
okay I can you know there there are
there are known musical traditions in I
assume every Latin American country and
I don't off the top of my head no
uh I'm embarrassed to say I don't know
for sure I'm wondering if Cumbia is uh
is actually the the club but I guess I
didn't mean to put you on the spot at
all I was wondering if you felt like you
were hearing something that was
Colombian specific or if it was sort of
you know Latin American rock it was
young modern sophisticated Rock and the
things that they chose to cover
reflected the same thing so like you
know Radiohead that's not the average
band you hear covered yeah
um but here it was
um so anyway
life looked surprisingly normal The
Masks were completely at odds with that
interpretation
and what I concluded was
Colombians have lived
um under
various kinds of tyranny lots of it
driven by American drug policy great
right so they've lived under
basically a regime in which they lack
control at the large scale and so what I
concluded was that what I was watching
was people who had learned to sort of
send whatever signal you need to send to
Authority so that it leaves you alone
enough that you can live in the
interstitial space and that's your life
and if you know if if decades at a time
are going to be lived under a tyrannical
regime you have to figure out how to do
the stuff of Life under its nose without
getting its attention yeah this is
actually consistent with um the next new
piece of art that we have coming out
that's going to be on merchandise that
we're working with our amazing artists
on right now which emerges from a line
that you gave I think at the end of the
last live stream or maybe it was two
live streams ago which is lie to a
tyrant yeah right like you know what do
what you have to do
uh to you know to be real and honest and
uh and what it sounds like what you're
saying even though there's not a
particular Tyrant uh here that you're
referring to whether I told Colombia uh
like you know give the little nod to the
authorities and then get on with your
life and then get on with your life you
know like in between places that it's
watching right so anyway I thought this
was great this sort of
um a sort of reminded me both the fact
of Colombia having gone from a place
that was totally unsafe to a place that
is now safe enough that at least I
didn't feel threatened walking around
yeah
um that is heartening right they've gone
from a regime that was completely
intolerable you know at the height of
the drug war and uh the the farc
revolution
um to a state that is
totally recognizable and you know I mean
let's put it this way
um life there
is crazy and the people there are crazy
but they're not as crazy as we are right
we're all crazy all people all these
cultures have their own idiosyncrasies
and so what's the what's I I guess I
didn't expect you to say that what's the
crazy that you think you do see well I
mean first of all this this is this is
another topic we're talking about there
is a way in which in Latin America you
and I have seen this so many different
ways
life is unfortunately cheap and it's
very disturbing to see it right the the
uh exhaust that comes out of a truck
that you can't get out from behind is
absolutely toxic and it's not even
regulations nobody's even notices it
it's so ubiquitous that it's just like
well what would I even do to notice that
some toxin is being spewed into the car
I'm traveling right
um people interestingly
people a huge percentage of the
population on the roads is on
motorcycles right
a lot of people aren't wearing helmets
people are you know women with their you
know seven-year-old kid on the
motorcycle going to school right all
sorts of stuff that would jar you if you
saw it here
um is commonplace I saw one very funny
instance
um we were out in the in the back
country really quite remote and a child
on a motorcycle he must have been 12
years old at most on a full-size adult
motorcycle just him just him uh bear he
had no shirt on as I recall it certainly
no helmet right nothing like protective
gear right he's on this bumpy road yep
he's got two pieces of rough hewn lumber
from obviously the local Mill like
dimensional Lumber but rough few really
rich what kind of boards you would see
you know used to siding yeah siding make
a roof something
um but anyway he had the front of these
boards which were probably eight feet
long ten feet long tied to the back of
the motorcycle and the back is dragging
on the ground and he was just motoring
by yeah I mean it was Charming he
definitely solved the problem of how
you're gonna get the lumber home but
um you know there was a way in which
there was so much
and also I I have to say I just can't
even solve this puzzle
somehow these back roads in Colombia
there is always exactly enough room for
whatever two vehicles have just met to
pass there's like you know three or four
centimeters beyond that
but it doesn't matter right it could be
two cars it's three or four centimeters
if you're up in the 80s are you
sometimes there's like a precipitous
drop on one side or were you not enough
oh yeah there was all kinds of well I
mean at the very least there are gullies
where if you were you know a few
centimeters too far you might end up
sliding over and being stuck there all
night but setting over in stock is
different from falling into the abyss
right no it's definitely preferable I
think so without being all the way at
good you know
but okay so there's a way in which
um life is cheap in a way that is
familiar from the developing world but
what really struck me was that I was now
that familiar there's nothing I can do
about the danger so I'm just not going
to let it rule my life thing that
happens in the developing world I am now
detecting that in the so-called first
world life has become very very cheap oh
um well I mean if you think about all
the things that have taken place during
covid
um the fact that
you've got you know
huge numbers of Adverse Events the Press
isn't very interested in figuring out
what they are you know we're kind of not
doing autopsies unless we absolutely
have to there's a way in which
um you know we're normalizing
absurdly tragic deaths right very young
people and says oh you know young people
sudden adult death syndrome strikes
again
um and so anyway
there's always you know that jarring
comparison between your culture and
really any other culture I mean it even
exists with the tiny little distinctions
between US and Canada and the bigger the
gap between your culture and somebody
else's the more profound the comparison
is but these comparisons now are
revealing things a
we're more traumatized than the
Colombians by what we've just been
through right maybe they were toughened
up by what they went through in the
period before
well it sounds like actually I actually
don't know but I know like we were also
told that we must accept
more stupid things so they were told to
mask and they were at least vaccine
mandates for visitors but and I don't
know specifically about this so it's
possible I'm wrong here but I know that
in many of the Latin American countries
Ecuador Mexico uh Costa Rica I believe
and I and I think this is pretty much
across the board that early treatment
was available over the counter
from the beginning basically that there
was no attempt and I remember like the
The Head of State in El Salvador was
busy talking about vitamin D early on
too yeah but you know the the drugs that
you know we shall never mention by name
for fear that we somehow become
re-demonetized even though we were still
demonetized
um were just available and people were
using them and they were even in
um they were even being given out by
governments in Mexico
um as you know understood it to be early
treatment and in some cases prophylaxis
packs so you know that you know it's
possible that some Latin American
country didn't do that but I don't know
that to be the case and so
um even if you know many people are
still masked and we know there would
have been vaccine requirements uh until
recently at least for visitors that
doesn't mean the degree to which
basically the gaslighting of the
populace was happening at the same level
that it was in the United States and
Canada and the UK and Australia and New
Zealand basically the English-speaking
countries of the Western World had such
an extraordinary degree of gaslighting
such an extraordinary degree of like
well if you're trying to figure out
what's going on you must be guilty of
Miss dis and Mal information so we're
going to shut you down and it just went
it just went counter to everything and
and I think to your point and that was
such a switch from what we had come to
expect
whereas the Colombians having been
effectively held hostage by not a
government but a
set of organizations that were outside
of the government for so many years came
to figure out how to sort of
pretend to pay Allegiance and then go on
with their lives
yeah I think this is
quite the case that effectively under
tyranny I think I believed this under
tyranny one is always gaslit and if you
have had enough of that in your history
so that you've kind of gotten used to
the idea that certain channels are
compromised and they'll say stuff to you
and it may even govern what you have to
do but privately you don't have to
believe it right that that gives you a
kind of immunity and what happened in in
the United States at least was that
people
were used to these channels being noisy
but they were not anywhere near prepared
for the order of magnitude of [ __ ]
that flowed through them and so you know
I mean this really is what the big lie
means right the big lie is the LIE is so
big that you can't imagine it's a lie
because it just it's beyond uh what
would incredibly be misrepresented
[Music]